je suis personnellement je n'engage pas
la famille politique défavorable à la
prolongation de dupas sanitaires sur une
période aussi longue pour une raison
très simple c'est ça veut dire vous
auriez été d'accord pour prolonger mais
moins longtemps je pense que jusqu'au
quai no 15 novembre et c'est ce qui
était prévu c'est le bon et je pense
qu'il ne faut pas aller au delà je mets
le même si elle même s'il ya un risque
de reprise et puis d'un coup il ya
toujours un risque la vie elle est faite
de risque et de la vie politique elle
est faite de risque aussi et la vie
sanitaire elle est faite de risque est
ce que pour autant il nous faut
abandonner l'essentiel de ce qui fait
notre vie démocratique la liberté nos
concitoyens la réponse est non et la
main du législateur elle doit trembler à
chaque fois qu'il s'est agi d'aller vers
la facilité la facilité c'est la
prolongation du passani terre la
difficulté c'est l' équilibre entre nos
libertés individuelles et la
responsabilité sanitaires et je pense
que c'était qui bourrent la commande de
s'arrêter au 13 novembre et de retrouver
des outils si nécessaire lorsque la
crise pourrait reprendre ce qui a priori
n'est pas le cas et comme le pire n'est
jamais sûr on doit pouvoir aussi
desserrer les règles y compris sur le
pass annie terre
[Musique]